c'est le moment il est temps pour nous
d'écouter la colère du peuple français
gronder par l'organe démesurée du
procureur général de la république des
proches française à bout des choses à
dire germaine maintenant ce que tu
m'avais dit le contraire c'est pas moi
d'en parler c'est lui je dormais la
désormais françaises français belges
belge mon président mon chien ma
maîtresse ma chienne mon chanteur toutou
fils monsieur leur tourneur à la terre
bien parisien mesdames et messieurs les
jurés public chéri mon amour
[Applaudissements]
si j'ai bien compris le chef
d'accusation m'étonnerait ben et moi
aussi ça le jeu dc pour bien marquer
qu'il ne s'agit là que d'une hypothèse
non pas que je ne comprenne pas les
chefs d'accusation que si le président
mais le plus souvent je n'ai rien à
[ __ ]
si j'ai bien compris le chef
d'accusation pierre vassiliu la société
dont je suis le vigile en chien de garde
vous reproche des pratiques et la
chanson d'une main et les chèvres de
l'autre mais voilà t'il point que le
doute et l'incrédulité se font jour dans
votre regard chafouin de brut cégétiste
c'est bien ce que je craignais je n'ai
pas très bien saisi toutes les finesses
de ce chef d'accusation
oserais-je l'avouer monsieur facile vu
votre chef d'accusation étaient
élaborées seulement cette nuit noire des
circonstances peu propice à la réflexion
sereine qu'exige habituellement les
grandes décisions judiciaires
le président et moi même étions à
l'hostellerie du mandrin frémissant à
sucy en brie
sinon superlight que les yvelines à sucy
en brie où l'on fêtait dans la liesse le
premier anniversaire de mongolie et
l'angola les jumelles de denise fabre
[Applaudissements]
écoutez à ne sont pas elles sont pas là
pour se défendre énormément et est
incapable alors quelque chose c'est pour
ça que j'en parle faut bien dire qu'elle
à voir la dimension du titre que la
grande presse traditionnelle a consacré
à cet événement on n'en mesure la portée
de chiots de chiottes inventé
internationale le pape qui en a de
lui-même
alors que pie xii avait 12 mamelles
comme son nom l'indiqué le pape qui
s'appelle de lui-même a été le premier
adressé un télégramme de félicitations à
la maman pour son double exploit tandis
que monsieur lech walesa négocier une
nouvelle trêve dans l'avenant l'avancent
des tanks soviétiques
le temps pour lui de dire une messe en
l'honneur de ses deux adorables poupées
net à la cathédrale st coco de varsovie
mais quelle soirée avec villers mes
enfants le président et moi avions eu
l'excellente idée de laisser notre
maîtresse d'armand à paris afin qu'elle
put en toute tranquillité afin qu'elle
put en toute tranquillité la veine
europe austère à la maison grâce au
battoir paf paf de boules une ex
moulinex libère la conne
un moment ça c'est frais ça le président
et moi en étions à finir d'éclusés notre
premier baril de 20 des branches et le
velours des métastases
je ne changerai pas mon bar il devint
débrancher contre deux barils d'un
cancer ordinaire les 40 majorettes de
sucy-en-brie était tout à jouer sur
notre table quand je mets criaient
soudain bon sang mais c'est bien sûr
c'est bien mûr c'est bien sûr on a
oublié vassiliou ah bon dit le président
il me fixait d'un oeil sartrien c'est à
dire droit dans les oreilles
avec autant d'intérêt qu'un délégué de
l'azerbaïdjan en écoutant les aventures
du plan quinquennal racontée par pépé
brejnev au kremlin beaulieu stover les
chicros colosse ljubi sauvier soucier
the grudge comme miss cap ou pas cap coz
garbit comme la main puis le président
villers ajouta vinci lui qui s'est élevé
à je vous en prie wallemme parlant je ne
vous ai pas interrompu alors je vous en
prie je vous en prie je vous en prie
laissez moi laissez moi terminer je vous
en prie laissez moi finir ma tartine
vous n'avez pas le monopole du beurre je
ne suis pas du palais madame darlan je
devine je devine votre regard faut de
yens grimaçante derrière vos seins noir
noir ce sont mes lunettes [ __ ] alors là
écoutez je dis non monsieur le président
je vous fais juge
je vous fais témoin ce genre de
plaisanterie racisme n'a pas sa place
dans ce tribunal où nos amis africains
ont les mêmes droits que les autres
[ __ ] craignez la colère du peuple
m'aime darlan et craignait aussi que ce
genre de plaisanterie odieuse de se
retourne à jour contre vous et plutôt
que vous ne croyez qu'ils cessent elles
plantier voulu entendre ça que d'être
maigre que d'être sourd que d'être mal
entendants mais la lave du drapeau
n'attend pas la planche à colombes adam
mais reprenons là où j'ai été coupé
comme disait abella remportant ses abats
l'hôpital les mails
[Rires]
facile lui qui sait si c'est pas le
plombier sans qui le massif central en
débouchant le second fut mais enfin
claude car il me permet de l'appeler
claude enfin claude m'écriai mme
vassiliou pierre vassiliu celui qui
chantait atteinte à venir ça serait son
tube gaston yatai les fonds qui sont
ayez jamais person qui répond tout de go
mais non dits villers ça c'était josé
ferrer effectivement je m'étais trompé
le gardien de chèvres
d'ailleurs au passage je suis président
je vous signale que ce n'est pas josé
ferrer c'est mel ferrer
josé ferrer rappelez vous c'est celui
qui faisait la chipolata dans la
saucisse de toulouse lautrec
le film de pierre granier où on me dit
de faire qui relatait la vie tumultueuse
de m.le modigliani au moulin de la
galette non au président le tube de
pierre vassiliu il y en eu plusieurs
mais celui qui le fit littéralement
explosé en 73 c'était qu'est ce que
c'est qu'est ce qu'il a acquis ces
cellules à damier écoutez maintenant le
jury mettez moi que vous passez les
bornes il peut arriver que le ton des
débats dans notre sympathique tribunal
d'exception se fasse quelques fois léger
voire mutins afin de faire oublier un
peu à l'innocent qui est la hantise la
guillotine qu'il redoute
et pas seulement à roubaix et il a peur
légitime qui l'habite et pas seulement
c'est le bras
[Rires]
mais le président je renonce et puisque
cette femme me fait devenir chèvre
je sais ce qu'il me reste à faire je
vais m'engager dans la légion étrangère
à dieu et non non
[Musique]